[Music]
hi guys
okay i have a secret obsession and it is
with stains
no in fact i stand
for stains and the reason i messed that
up is because stan is a new word to me
apparently it means stalker and fan it
was kind of originated by eminem
so i'm definitely going with it so
i'm a stan for stains the bigger
the tougher the stickier the better
i'm a mom so this was like kind of
perfect i my passion works
i love concocting the perfect solutions
products combinations treats treatments
methodologies tools are very important
process is important so i asked some
people to send me in their
stains and then i'm going to help them
figure out how to fix it
let's see how this goes okay first julia
sent us a video take a look hi drew
my name is julia morales and i'm from
chicago illinois
and i need your help girl you have no
idea
i love to party i had a really great
party but a couple of friends of mine
have spilled some fruit punch on
my carpet and i'm supposed to be moving
and my landlord said he's going to
charge me
if i don't get that stain up i have no
idea how to get this out rue
please please please please help me okay
first of all julia we both know that
that isn't juice
and second of all if it's really wine i
need to know that because it takes a
different method but let's just pretend
it's juice
here is everybody's first mistake in my
opinion
if you get stuff in your carpet do not
leave it till the next day
you want to have it be wet because
that's how the absorption happens
don't think oh i'll attack that later
you won't
it's set in at that point you can still
fix it make it a part
of the party hey i'm still grooving and
talking but i'm doing this at the same
time
okay like the fun doesn't have to stop i
mean
as far as i'm concerned the fun just
started
but seriously like don't think that's a
next day
project i'm not a righteous person but
i'm kind of righteous about stains
don't push on it lift
absorb you want to gently tap
a very absorbent thing when people go in
and start doing this i'm like
so this i am literally i am like it's
like
a a bunny's paw on cotton
you're gonna pat kind of like you're the
bunny going like
hey i want some of that like hey
then you can take a multitude of stain
removals
so i'm gonna take my trusty draft also
don't put a ton of stuff on a stain
like be gentle with it it's like
you know think baby bunny when it comes
to stains
how are we looking
thank you this is important to me
i'm single i live with my two children
and how i party and get off in my free
time
is i kill stains okay
so if you have one i'm interested all
right
i want to party let's do this michael i
understand
you have a stain show me what you got
hey drew my name is michael redden i'm a
real estate agent from whippany new
jersey
and i love eating ice cream
unfortunately
when i eat ice cream i get a little bit
into it and i wound up
staining my favorite white shirt with
chocolate ice cream
i need to get this stain out i don't
know what to do drew
i need some help listen it happens this
is nothing chocolate is nothing again
this is why
yeah that's right the draft is coming
back out
all right now this time i'm gonna treat
the draft
very differently i mean this is like
literally finding your soulmate i'm not
kidding
i love you oh sherry
you set my soul on fire
that's what i do to my daughter olive
all the time it's from a tom and jerry
cartoon
and she goes mom
probably because you know i don't know
about you but i just live to embarrass
my children
so i'm just using my fingertip
so at this point if you want you can
start to
gently again think bunny
so i'm trying to make this go a little
faster because we have a lot of other
things to accomplish today but
i am in my happy place right now
here's another tip the fibers actually
can work
as an abrasiveness so you can actually
start to rub it together
if you don't have a toothbrush handy
water in the bowl
excellent okay this is pure water oh
it's
warm too
all right now normally i would put this
under a big running faucet
wring it dry and then present you
with your shirt i want you to find that
chocolate god darn it
that's right that's right
bring me your stains
i want the challenge this is my happy
place
bring it on what have you got for me
look maybe i need to go get a life but
you know what
i don't care i love stain removal
i do stand for stains
we'll be right back
[Music]
you